lustiger level cell nein ich lasse das
nicht und habe meine hand herzlich
willkommen hier zu einem neuen video und
zwar haben wir viele leute gesagt ich
soll mal das spiel spielen das sei wohl
irgendwie ganz cool ich hatte mir das
damals schon mal runtergeladen viele
meinten das sei irgendwie den charts wo
ist das denn in den charts achter platz
55 neues so mal schauen was dieses spiel
damit sich bringt ich habe extra den ton
vor dem spiel aus man gleich mir nicht
sicher bin ob die musik copyright ist
oder wie oder bar oder als erhalten
wissen es deswegen hab ich ja jetzt
selber eigene musik eingefügt wir fangen
einfach mal an mit level 1 tupperware
team uwe dort interviews oracle jd
kunden mission zackig hobby einfach mal
alle daran hier müssen halt quasi sinn
des spiels müssen diese teile da
irgendwie rein rasseln ohne dass wir
irgendwie mit anderen punkten in
berührung kommen also wir können jetzt
auch hier beispielsweise mal drei
untereinander reinpacken
oder halt immer was soll ich euch doch
mal ton machen
ich weiß nicht mal jetzt ton an
vielleicht ist es ja auch so laut ich
weiß nicht vielleicht ist es gut mit und
bereitet ja auch mich schon recht lauten
ton also alle vier hammer geschäfte
machen jetzt mal eben hier level-5 das
ist natürlich auch kein ding hier für
den king
ich weiß nicht was alles also bisher
geht es klar viele meinten das sei halt
so sehr sehr rage lustig dass ich danach
dann halt wieder richtig ausrasten werde
aber bisher geht es echt klar oh gott
ich muss da schon neun von den teilen
reinpacken halter
das wird ja immer der allerletzte dk es
war der allerletzte kommen jetzt hier
ist da nicht so schwer luca nimmt der
einfachen beispiel an dir selbst weil du
bist cool du müsstest das ja schon
schaffen
da ist das ding jetzt habe ich mir so
circa alles verbaut ich muss noch drei
dinge da irgendwie reinpacken faktisch
achter corp
nach einer level 9 durch und jetzt nein
ich brauche keine routenplaner ich krieg
das schon selber hin irgendwie zum ziel
zu kommen ich werde jetzt versuchen
immer direkt zwei reinzuhauen das ist
doch nicht war das gar nicht so schwer
sein
jetzt noch 12 level cell nein ich lasse
mir das nicht und habe meine hand
letztes geduscht und da waren hier schon
so richtige spielen dann war ich immer
auf den tisch schlagen wenn ich aufnehme
das ist voll dumme angewohnheit mich so
bin irgendwie ein bisschen [ __ ]
gerade ich weiß nicht wo ich jetzt dies
das ist doch nicht das war noch so mega
klar ist damit dass dann einfach nicht
zuteil die scheiße hier dem skill level
12 genau das gleiche eine andere
richtung wieder vier kann auch einer hin
da kann noch einer hin und da der
allerletzte und das war so eng
zeige mir wie ich nach oben komme nö wir
will nach rügen jetzt hier ich muss es
doch wohl hinkriegen da irgendwie jetzt
diese teilnehmer rhein zu ballern
auch das ist doch nicht da da kann auch
hier einfach mal ein bisschen hero rock
und da ist die zwölf auch schon durch
dann machen wir ihm vorgestern schnell
liga wie soll ich das denn hinkriegen
nein ich erzähle euch meine geschichte
von einem scharf da war ein schaf und es
hat sehr sehr viel wolle gehabt deswegen
wird es dann irgendwann geschoren und
dann wird aus der wolle unfassbar
schöner pulli und dieser pulli ist
bestimmt etwas ganz schönes an dass ich
jetzt denke damit ich doch dieses level
irgendwie mal schaffen kann dass das
kann nicht sein das ist meine fresse ist
das schnell
oh mein gott wie kann man das denn so
schnell spinnen dicker kommen jetzt wo
es noch platz hier ist noch platz
doch das war auch wieder so eng das ist
doch ich darf ich denke dann immer ich
muss da ganz schnell zwischen also ich
schätze guck ich schätze die
geschwindigkeit falsch ein ich ich ich
hab ich hab schon noch mehr zeit
so muss ich das sehen so so so so so so
so der allerletzte mal wieder das ist
nicht wahr
es kann nicht sein dass europa gewollt
gar nicht wissen wie mein ipad von
hinten aussieht er das hat überall
schrammen weil ich das immer auf dem
tisch bretter er das kann ich nicht
sagen egal wenn ihr auf die werbung
klingt kann ich mir bestimmt noch mal
wieder irgendwann neues equipment zulegt
schon wieder eines ipads bin übrigens am
überlegen ob ich mir eine apple watch
holen soll
ich weiß nicht ob der bock drauf weil
ich halt total der apple fan bin weil
ich einfach auf dinge mit design stehe
und die apple watch ist einfach so ein
ding also wenn einer von euch eventuell
bei den video days ist erwartet wenn das
video kommt ich bin gerade am
vorproduzieren für die ich will dieses
eintritt auf den tisch hauen aber ich
kann es nicht weil das tier das ist doch
nicht darum man also wenn ihr zufällig
zu dem video days kommt und bock habt
mir eine apple watch zu schenken dann
werde ich euch selber traut wenn ihr mir
geschenkt wenn ihr dann beispielsweise
noch einen ferrari dabei habt oder so
würde ich dir natürlich auch nehmen
würde ich dann auch ein foto im gegenzug
muss halt machen allgemein werden fotos
mit mir 20 euro kosten damit ich einfach
ein bisschen meine that he was ist denn
so schwer level 14
das ist einfach mega sie im vergleich zu
level 13 58 gott ich muss so viele
bretter da reinhauen
nein wenn ich ein lebensziel habe dann
ist es der b 14 bei nicht mal wieder
diese werbung sehen wo kate absolut
spielt ab tonnen ab uptown ich werde
auch kommt es gar nicht richtig
ausgesprochen wird aber die ist sehr
sehr geil oder hat in seinem werbespot
damit gemacht für auch so ein komisches
strategiespielen jetzt den allerletzten
wo setzt die letzten in ohio level 14
freunde level 15 wird das aller letzte
sein was ich hier spielen werde weil ich
unbedingt noch mathe lernen muss alle
level 15 noch neugeschäft ich weiß ich
habe eigentlich gesagt level 15 wir das
letzte sein aber bisher verliefen spiel
noch nicht so richtig aufgeregt deswegen
werde ich einfach level 16 auch noch mal
schnell schaffen ist kein linken king
ich weiß ich wenn ich da raus cook ist
da der wunderschönsten sonnenuntergang
der welt also ich wohne halt direkt da
dass mir die sonne quasi so ins in
zimmer reinsch ein wunderschönes wetter
ist unter sind gerade so schöne wolken
davon muss ich erst mal ein foto machen
wo man hinsieht wird euch ja unfassbar
gern das tolle fotos zeigen was ich dort
aufgenommen habe allerdings würdet ihr
dann einfach sehen quasi wo ich wohne
und das möchte ich natürlich auch nicht
so gern deswegen mache ich noch mal eben
schnell hier level 17 zu ende
bei level 17 mit absolut das aller
letzte sein was ich eben noch hier
rasieren werde weil ihr müsst ja
bedenken ich schreibe wirklich ich weiß
nicht ob ich schon mal gesagt habe aber
ich schreibe
nach dem video days eine klausur also
direkt am montag schreibe ich eine
heftige wirtschafts matte und stoller
statistik klausur und dafür bin ich
jetzt schon die ganze zeit am lernen und
ich muss ja auch noch videos produzieren
der punkt wo am level 18
speaking das ist nicht wahr das ist
nicht wahr als ob das auf einmal so mega
crazy wieder wird auch das kann doch
nicht sein hier die scheiße da level 19
geballert jetzt kommt level 20 hier
wieder auch es ist doch nicht war als ob
die so oft einfach ihren speed wechseln
was gibt's denn da sonst noch so für
zusatzfunktionen später ich glaube ich
auch die taktik raus waren die in ihren
speed verändern
immer wenn diese dicken dinger kommen
ich warte einfach ab bis die rinspeed
verändern
jetzt ha ausgetrickst die scheiße das
kann doch nicht so schwer sein sorgt
hier komm ich mache jetzt mal eben
schnell nein ich zeig dir keine lasagne
rezepte aus der nächste italiener lassan
jetzt ist der san italienisch oder ich
würde sagen dass war es hier von diesem
video ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen
wenn ihr noch mal wollte dass ich spiele
oder irgend andere spiel dann schreibt
der spieler die kommentare oder schreibt
aber in die kommentare ich würde mich
über den daumen hoch freuen weil ich an
solchen videos halt echt immer so zwei
drei stunden dann sitze ich weiß viele
youtuber machen videos aber let's play
sind halt echt so die sind weiß echt
nicht aufwendig aber bei mir ist es halt
so dass ich mit einmal relativ viel mühe
mit gebe deswegen sehe ich da ran halt
immer ob es euch gefallen hat oder nicht
deswegen würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen wir sehen uns dann oder
haben uns auf dem video days gesehen ich
weiß nicht genau wann ich dieses video
veröffentlichen werde bevor jetzt noch
mehr werbung kommt sage ich einfach